so a lot of Earth slowly grinds
world-building is pretty political like
possessed yes um
how did that influence you and was that
something you ever discussed and also do
you think it explicitly colored your
approach to the Marshall G well thank
you for that yes yes and yes and I'm
glad you brought it up because again if
I had had more time I'd talk about it
and I will now Ursula's politics were
American leftist of a different variety
than mine but we were both the kind of
American left sister said look the front
is borrowed and we just take our
different points of view and work
together rather than the narcissism of
small differences we're left us fight
leftist because they're the only people
that understand the nature of the
argument so the dispossessed is an
anarchist text and Men it is a very
interesting and compelling thought
experiment what would it be like to live
in an anarchist society because really
anarchism is almost like you know it's
almost politically autistic where
everybody's free and in everybody free
contract between everybody and there are
no rules and she actually wrote me one
of these emails to thank me for my
introduction to magpie killjoys
anarchist I wrote the introduction I
said Anarchy can mean no rules or no
ruler in the Greek and I say it means no
ruler because you have to have rules and
even on enorus there's rules in the
anarchistic society it's like management
of the Commons the Commons was not a
space where he could do anything it was
managed and regulated and anarchism as I
understand it will be a complete
horizontal ization of power and wealth
and that's the anarchist goal a distant
horizon that everybody should be
shooting for and so she and I came at it
from our different angles I'm much more
of a Marxist Leninist and Anna statist
and so she her anarchism as she told me
came out of the daodejing
and share her translation of the Dao de
Jing is fabulously good and you need to
cross-reference it with three or four
others to realize how amorphous and
murky that
Cayman is its but she's she comes to
anarchism from the Dow and and from that
strain of Chinese literature that I
think comes also from her father and the
anthropological strain so this is what
and also I stayed up all night to read
the dispossessed I had a little science
fiction library club a hardback it was
like short and light I got to what I
call the Dickinson point which is the
point where you know you have to finish
this book in that city comes from Peter
Dickinson who does it all the time but I
got to that point with her and was like
1 a.m. so I stayed up to like 4 a.m. to
read the dispossessed and when I was
done I was thinking you can write a
utopian novel and make it work as a
novel and that blew my mind
that was 1975 and and it was a huge
impact on the Mars trilogy and
everything that I've done since probably
in in terms of the content of rather
than the form the content her influence
comes to me mostly from left-handed
darkness and from the dispossessed as a
gender and politics so she was really
important and I know she still is to all
anarchists and and all American leftists
who are thinking about it so thank you
and you know when you look at the
left-handed Len of dark left a note of
darkness it's a novel about refugees and
culture clash it's a novel about gender
and and sort of levels of trust it's a
it's a it's a novel where a society sees
a potential to progress that's kind of
offered to them and and doesn't sure if
it's gonna kind of take the offer I mean
two sides of two societies actually on
on that planet so it's it's a pretty
interesting foil for for the moment
we're in now with just some of those
things yeah a left hand is a great novel
I would say it's her masterpiece and and
one of the great novels of the 20th
century and it has to do with a couple
of things the the car hide is futile the
other Society on the other side of the
world is socialist in a bad Soviet
there isn't a capitalist society there's
only these two struggling and both of
them mired in their problems so it has a
lot of interesting political thoughts I
think she was thinking that maybe the
two of them together was a portrait of
the United States in the 1960s partly
futile and partly bad socialism but no
no no function no real culture and then
the gender thing for me was that most of
the time gender isn't important for
social life sometimes it is pay
attention to that and when I might when
my wife and I had our first kid then
she's a scientist working 12 hours a day
six days a week and when my boy was 10
weeks old which I took over and was was
a caretaker of this child mr. mom as
they put it in the great movie by
Michael Keaton I was mr. mom for years
and the left hand of darkness this idea
the king was pregnant which obviously I
wasn't but the King did a lot of bottle
feedings you know they were very
maternal in their affect and I thought
yeah man I what left hand help me was to
conceptualize the feelings that I had
the structure of feeling had changed
because of that book so I was just in
Kemmer had come along and I was in in my
female existence and I was really happy
I was I thought I was pretty good at it
so you know this is this is profound
what literature can do for you and and
she knew that I think she knew she had
hit it out of the park with that book
[Music]